[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime All Pro and in this video we
will be talking about zelgius the
younger brother of Melly Otis whose
ultimate fate remains a mystery as of
the making of this video a fact that
underscores even further the tragic
nature of the life that zelgius has led
up to this point a video on zelgius has
been highly requested by literally
hundreds of you guys especially with the
latest events in the manga turning out
the way that they did so thank you all
for the requests in this video I will
examine the tragic life of zeldron
and I will argue that although it may
not seem that way at first zelgius is
actually one of the more developed
characters in the seven deadly sins and
probably the biggest unsung hero of the
entire story Before we jump into it I
want to give a huge thank you to raid
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
rain shadow Legends is a mobile RPG that
breaks the mold challenges your
expectations and immerses you in its
amazing story line awesome 3d graphics
and epic action including giant boss
fights PvP battles and hundreds of
unique champions that you can collect
and customize I did not expect this
level of detail and performance out of a
mobile game look how crazy the level of
detail is on these champions and it's
not just their design the champions have
their own unique style and attitude that
makes them really interesting as
characters raid is getting big real fast
and with the good reason so be sure to
jump in early and get a huge head start
on the competition there is a special
launch tournament coming up with crazy
prizes and if you go to the description
of this video right now and download
raid exclusively through my link you
will get 50,000 in silver immediately
and you will get a free epic champion on
top of that as part of the new player
program courtesy of the dev team try it
out for yourself
right now the game is totally free on
Android and iOS quick warning this video
will feature manga spoilers everything
related to Zell dress that has been
covered in the manga is fair game
with that said proceed with caution you
have been warned when we first meet Zell
Dru's he is serving as the piety of the
ten commandments and as the demon Kings
representatives so he is the
facto leader of the group in the
beginning zelgius is portrayed as a
villain and his hatred for his own
brother Mellie Otis the hero of our
story instantly makes us think that Zell
drous is the bad guy once he is released
from the coffin of eternal darkness
zelgius wants to exact revenge on Mellie
Otis for betraying the demon clan 3,000
years ago and siding with the goddesses
enact which ultimately led to the demons
being sealed inside the coffin in the
first place this is a pretty simple
setup for a villain evil demon Prince is
angry about his brother's betrayal and
wants to get revenge zelgius has a cool
character design especially since his
appearance is so similar to Mellie Otis
and he is a strong and determined
villain which makes him a fun character
to watch but it doesn't make him a
particularly deep character however if
there is one thing that the seven deadly
sins series does extremely well it is
developing characters and uncovering
their individual complexities beyond
just our first impressions of them
growing up as the younger brother of
Mellie Otis and the youngest son of the
demon king zelgius would have had a very
difficult family dynamic
Mellie Otis always had incredible
potential as a demon and the demon king
calls him the source of destruction
because of this meliodas was always
presumed to be the heir to the demon
king's throne and zelgius was always
meant to simply remain in melioidosis
shadow before he met elizabeth meliodas
was known as the strongest and most
ruthless warrior of the demon clan and
zelgius was merely the younger less
powerful brother but there were also
some benefits to growing up as the
brother of Mellie Otis including the
fact that zelgius had the opportunity to
train with his brother and due to his
brother's immense power this meant that
zelgius had the opportunity to keep
getting stronger another very important
aspect of zelda says difficult family
situation is of course his father the
demon king we don't know who the mother
of Medicine's ljust was or what she was
like but we know that the demon king is
a ruthless ruler with serious trust
issues because he was betrayed multiple
times including by the original demon
and then later by Mellie Otis the demon
king doesn't trust anyone and he values
power and control above all else the
reason he values power and control is
because being completely in control
reduces the chances of someone betraying
you or stabbing you in the back
and because he is so obsessed with
control the demon king considers the
things that cannot be controlled such as
love and compassion to be signs of
weakness growing up with a father who
rejects all forms of emotion including
love and compassion and values only
ruthless power and control would be
difficult for anyone and zelgius is no
exception by the way if you would like
to know more about the psychology of the
demon king and why he became the type of
person he is today feel free to check
out my video on the demon king and his
psyche link in the description now just
try to put yourself in zelgius shoes he
grew up in the shadow of his older and
stronger brother and he grew up with a
father who valued power above all else
so naturally the father would prefer to
stronger brother and treat the younger
and weaker brother less favorably the
demon king makes it a point to mock the
idea of love and falling for a woman and
he calls anyone who falls in love weak
so it is likely that zelgius would have
internalized some of this contempt for
love when Mele Otis betrays the demon
clan because he fell in love with
Elisabeth zelgius is furious and he
wants revenge having been raised to
think that love is weakness zelgius
blames Elisabeth for corrupting his
brother and he initially shares his
father's disgust for what meliodas has
done at first glance it might appear
that zelda's grew up to become exactly
what his father wanted him to be a
ruthless demon prince who values only
power and loyalty and who scoffs at the
idea of love and emotion but there is
more to sell just a story we later
learned that despite of all the love
bashing that the demon king must have
exposed him to growing up zelgius did
eventually end up falling in love with a
woman named zelda who was a member of
the vampire clan during the previous
holy war the vampires were allied with
the demons but at some point the vampire
King is raff decided to rebel against
the demon king and for this betrayal the
demon king sentenced the entire vampire
clan to death what's more the demon king
sent zelgius to carry out the death
sentence precisely because he wanted to
remind eldress that he must be loyal to
the demon king above all else and that
he must never let a woman or feelings of
any kind get in the way however despite
all the indoctrination that he had been
exposed to for his entire life by the
demon king zell drous cannot bring
himself to kill gelda so he decides to
seal the vampires away instead of
killing them by doing this
zel just betrays his father and his
wishes and it isn't hard to see that
zelgius is apparent hatred for meliodas
and Elizabeth and their betrayal is in
part a manifestation of the self-hatred
that zelgius feels because he knows that
he also betrayed his father in the name
of love just like Mellie Otis
it might seem hypocritical for zelgius
to be angry at meliodas when he is also
guilty of a similar sin but it isn't
uncommon for someone who feels guilt
about their own actions to project that
guilt onto others and to be angry at
them because this is usually much easier
than actually coming to terms with your
own inner demons no pun intended
nonetheless zelgius does eventually come
to terms with his true feelings and he
decides that his love for gelda is more
important than his loyalty to a ruthless
and merciless father even though we find
out that he had hopes of becoming the
next demon king himself so that he could
free gelda and bring peace and harmony
to the underworld soldiers decides to
support his older brother Mellie Otis in
becoming the next demon king in return
for meliodas releasing gelda from the
seal so that they could finally be
together the demon king later mocks
zelgius his ambition to become the next
demon king and bring peace and harmony
to the clans of the underworld including
the demons and vampires but this
ambition that zelgius held tells us a
lot about what kind of person he
actually is even though he was raised by
the ruthless demon king Zell just wanted
to be a different kind of ruler someone
who governs through peace and harmony
rather than war and terror even though
he eventually gave up on his ambition to
become the demon king and decided to
support meliodas if he had become the
demon king it is clear that zelgius
would have ruled much differently from
his father he would not have considered
his love for gelda to be a weakness and
he would have tried to reconcile the
different factions of the underworld
instead of simply destroying all
perceived threats and rivals after
meliodas agrees to release gelda if he
becomes the demon king zelgius willingly
sacrifices himself multiple times in
order to make that happen he challenges
Eskin or Merle and Ludo shell Maya and
the others when they attempt to stop
meliodas from absorbing the commandments
and as we know as eldress takes a
significant amount of punishment as a
result and when it turns out that
malleolus had not become the demon king
but instead the demon king had possessed
his body zelgius decides to sacrifice
himself once again by taking the demon
hedaan and he is severely injured in the
process after this the ultimate fate of
zelgius remains unknown for multiple
manga chapters and this underscores the
nature of zelgius entire life
Zelda's grew up in difficult family
circumstances the son of a cruel and
ruthless father and the brother of
meliodas a stronger demon Prince and the
heir apparent to the demon king's throne
after meliodas the favorite son betrays
the demon clan zelgius is conflicted
between his loyalty to his father in the
clan and his relationship with his older
brother but more than that zel gist is
conflicted between the strict beliefs of
his father believes that condemn all
forms of emotion including love and his
own powerful feelings for gelda
just as meliodas bond and the other main
characters of the seven deadly sins
story struggle both externally and
internally throughout the series zelgius
also goes through this same type of
struggle eventually he decides to stand
up to his father he disobeys the command
to kill the vampires and he plans to
become a different kind of ruler when he
inherits the throne and once he realizes
that Mele Otis is the one who is more
likely to become the next demon king
zelgius decides to support him even at
the risk of losing his own life in this
sense zelgius really is the unsung hero
of the seven deadly sins story sure the
seven deadly sins and their friends are
all heroes too but we know that they are
because they are the main characters and
we recognize them as such but zelgius is
introduced later on in the story he
starts out as a villain and because he
sees the world from the perspective of
the demons it is easy to think of him as
the bad guy in reality when we think of
it from zelgius perspective he wanted to
bring peace and harmony to the
underworld even though that went against
the demon Kings wishes he spared the
vampires when he was commanded to kill
them all and he put his own life on the
line multiple times in order to do the
right thing in the end he risks his own
life to take his father on directly
despite the fact that his father had a
lifetime to indoctrinate him into his
own cruel system of belief zelgius might
not be a hero from the perspective of
the goddesses or the humans because he
was always seen as an enemy by them but
from the perspective of the demons the
vampires and the other creatures of the
underworld zelgius is a hero who was
willing to defy the most powerful
creature in the universe
and even sacrifices own life for a
better and more harmonious future for
all of them even though the manga
appears to have forgotten him for a
number of chapters we should not forget
zelgius or his sacrifice
after all what differentiates a decent
story from a great one is the ability to
develop not just one or two of your main
characters but also the less prominent
character and zelgius is a perfect
example of the ability of the seven
deadly sins story to give even side
characters a compelling character
progression so let me know what you guys
think do you agree with me that zelgius
is an unsung hero who lived a tragic
life but made the right choice in the
end
do you like cell just as a character and
what do you think will ultimately become
of him and gelda let me know down in the
comments if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell also be
sure to check out our sponsor raid
shadow legends link in the description
as always thank you guys so much for
watching thank you for requesting this
video and until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]